each year Microsoft Research hosts
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
it's my great pleasure today to
introduce Tony Hoare I think you all
know Tony from from his work but let me
just mention a couple of more recent
things one of which is that he just came
from receiving the prestigious John for
Norman award which for his contributions
to software design and he just told me
also that he is that he is going to
receive a cig plan Lifetime Achievement
Award in in January as well so without
any further ado let me Tony one more
share justification anybody like to sit
in my seat well thank you very much for
this invitation I've arrived in in
Redmond yes yesterday and I well I very
much invite enjoyed my visit so far I
hope you'll continue that tradition
thank you the algebra of concurrent
programming I've become interested in
concurrent programming in it's more in
its wider aspects and in recent years
with the advent of the multi-core
computer I previously have worked in
concurrent programming on the model of
disjoint communicating processors so in
both cases the development of my
thinking has been triggered by the
opportunities offered by the hardware
but what what my real ambition now is to
try to unify the ideas that are relevant
for reasoning about concurrency in both
both I say all its forms at least as
many as I can think of and to present
the results of the speculations in the
form of an algebra that
appeals to human ability and human
experience and maybe even interest in
the use of algebraic manipulations to
reason about mathematics arithmetic and
now about programs as well of course the
the ideas that I have I will present I
have stolen they have bare face idli
from a number of other people many of
them interns at Microsoft in Cambridge
algebra algebra uses variables to stand
for something and if I were a pure
mathematician I wouldn't worry what they
stood for at all but as an applied
mathematician and I expect most of you
belong to that category it's helpful to
know at least one of the things that the
variables of your algebra are standing
for and I'm going to tell you that my
intention is that they should stand for
computer programs computer program
designs and computer program
specifications I'm deliberately not
going to say which of those I'm talking
about at any given time because I want
to concentrate on their similarities
rather than their differences all three
describe what happens inside and around
a computer that executes a given program
and of the three kinds of description
the program itself is the most precise
in the sense that if the program it
doesn't say exactly what's going to
happen at least it the limits entirely
the limited freedom that the implement
has in implementing the program in
different ways so a program can be
non-deterministic but nevertheless it's
the most precise description you can get
of what the computer is going to do when
it executes the program specification
one would like that to be the most
abstract describing only those parts of
the behavior of the program that are are
of interest to its user and providing
perhaps some means by which the user can
predict and even control what that
program is going to do and designs of
what somewhere in between may come
between the s they are more specific
than the specification but perhaps less
specific than the eventual program is
going to be the program that implements
the design here are some examples of
program specifications and theirs or
designs I'm going to formulate them all
as statements about the execution of the
program so the concept of a post
condition is probably fairly familiar
with you a post condition describes all
programs which actually meet that post
condition or shall we say the execution
of all programs that meet that post
condition and so it is an assertion a
statement a description of all
executions that end with a given array
sorted for example quite often we
reasoned with conditional correctness
that is can be a description or which is
conditional on the ending of the
execution if the execution ends it ends
with a sorted but it doesn't say that
the execution will necessarily end
perhaps the execution will be infinite
precondition is very similar it
describes all executions which start
with that precondition true so for
example execution starts with X even and
a program lasts we come to something
like X becomes X plus 1 describes all
executions in which the final value of x
is 1 greater than the initial value here
are some examples which are slightly
more wide-ranging and they deal with
aspects of correctness of a program
which go beyond what can be expressed
simply by assertions or assertion or
reasoning the safety our condition which
I know Microsoft has been very
interested in is the statement of the
description of all programs that have no
buffer overflows terminations and for an
algorithm one wants the algorithm to
terminate and therefore the
specification would say that execution
is finite it always ends on the other
hand for an operating system you want
the opposite our specification that
there is no infinite amount of internal
activity in your program which could
prevent it from giving you a response to
an external stimulus no livelock in
other words fairness i've tended to
rather downplay the issue of fairness in
specifications but in general there's no
reason why we shouldn't regard fairer
executions as one of the things that we
want and that we want to describe by
means of a specification fairness
criterion like no response so a response
is always given eventually to each
request and finally even probability you
can describe executions in which the
ratio ratio of A's to B's tends to one
with time so over a long period of time
you'd expect an equal number of A's and
B's now that's just those are just
examples but the idea that one should
use the same conceptual framework for
programs and specifications and
assertions and designs is such I have
found such a novel one too
not so much to me but but to most
audiences that I've spoken to that I'd
like to justify it briefly the point is
really just to save effort and also to
unify
in general the concepts and reduce the
number of concepts that we need to
understand our particular branch of
science so as a result of this kind of
unification we can apply the same laws
same algebraic laws same reasoning
methods the same theorems to programs to
designs and to specifications we don't
need three different branches of our
subject to deal with those three
important phenomena other things that
the same laws are going to be reusable
for many kinds of correctness possession
or correctness fairness probability have
usually been dealt with by separate
branches of our subject with their own
axioms and their own reasoning methods
we can if we succeed in this unification
we will be able to apply the same laws
to reasoning about every form well many
forms of correctness and that's
important are too if we are building
tools because we'd like to be able to
use the same tools for many different
purposes not a special purpose tool for
dealing with fairness well that's the
ideal clearly when one comes to actually
build these tools you find that in order
to make them reasonably efficient you
need to specialize them to particular
kinds of problem particular kinds of
application and that is a very fair but
the important thing is that whatever
specializations you do you do it as part
of a framework in which all the tools
can play together so there is a common
grounding of ideas and concepts that can
be built in to the interfaces between
the tools and make sure that there is no
mismatch as a project moves from one
phase to another or as your programs
like sub programs are used in different
contexts it's understood how to link
those together it
require a vast engineering enterprise to
try to somehow adapt you interfaces
after they have been cast in concrete
now I didn't want to be could somebody
get me a bottle of water or something
please I have failed to provide myself
with that thank you restaurant now I
don't want to be religious about this
but basically my strategy is to unify
things first and then if necessary to
make distant distinctions after I know
enough about the subject to realize that
the distinctions are going to be
desirable or important or necessary and
so the distinctions are made within a
common framework within a common family
framework thank you very much oh great
and when the need for them is a parent
we will be able to motivate why the
distinction is made very often by
showing what additional laws we can get
by making the distinction the basic
basic laws which I'm going to develop
are based on the concept of refinement
refinement between between there are
objects of discourse and I can explain
refinement as more or less that
everything every aspect of the execution
described by the left-hand side of this
refinement symbol is also described by
the right-hand side q and it applies
equally in all combinations of cases
that I've described if we prove that a
specification implies a specification P
for it if P implies Q specifications
this certainly means that any
implementation of P implies in the
implementation sorry it also satisfies
the specification Q if the program P
satisfies Q that's our normal definition
of correctness
if program P is more determinate than a
program Q that also the the executions
which it can evoke are subset of those
which are described by Q and that means
that the program is more deterministic
now this refinement relation is used in
an idealistic development process for
programs which starts with a
specification and gradually refines the
specification to produce perhaps a
series of designs and eventually the
process ends in a successfully
delivered program which because the
whole design process has been supported
by the mathematical basis of the algebra
is known by construction to be correct
at the time when it is first submitted
to the computer well I've been an
academic most my life and as an academic
I felt free to pursue ideals which I
should have known were impossible
although I'm afraid I I didn't coming to
work for industry I now realize that
they're impossible but nevertheless very
important because research science is
driven by idealism it's not driven by
the profit motive and therefore we must
cultivate the ideals of scientists in
the hopes that they produce lovely ideas
which can then be exploited commercially
or in other ways now
also since joining Microsoft I realized
that program analysis which starts with
the program and tries to work out
aspects of its behavior is in practice
going to be at least in the short term
much more important than the ideal is
idealism of correctness by construction
and that's just the reverse processed
using the same operator of refinement
same comparative operator to start with
the program and somehow postulate what
design that program is is is conforming
to and maybe even aspects of the
specification of that program so that
justifies why we use an ordering to as
the basic algebraic or operator
unfortunately again the mathematicians
always use a lot of different words
almost any pair of words involving akka
paratus like bigger or better or greater
or weaker or upper or lower or more or
less or be included all of these words
are used to mean to denote a
relationship between what stands on the
left hand side of the refinement
relation and on the right hand side and
I shall probably follow the same
practice so let's start with the some of
the basic algebraic laws that refinement
is a partial order which you probably
know means that it's transitive
antisymmetric and reflexive why do we do
this how do we know that these laws are
actually true that's the wrong question
in algebra you don't know what you're
talking about
even so the question about whether it
might be true or not would be irrelevant
there's always true something you don't
well yes I think so
the but we do know what you're talking
about
and therefore we can ask is it is it
true under these algebraic properties of
the ordering of the relation actually
true that's the wrong question to do we
want them to be true that's the right
question because algebra is about
postulating laws it's not about proving
them and therefore you need to be
motivated to want the law to be true
rather than actually believe it to be
true yes is correct admission equality
he is a new driving sequence to clearly
imply each other they're not the same
statement yes what they're describing
the same thing and I'm always going to
concentrate from the thing that I'm
describing rather than just the
description of it that's that's being an
applied my applied mathematician of
course thank you so we want them to be
true if if the refine relation wasn't a
partial order we couldn't use it for the
stepwise development and/or analysis as
I described in the last program you've
got to make sure of the link between the
program and the specification at the two
ends of the chain and establish that
link by just checking that each smaller
link is actually valid anti-symmetric
means that two thing the switch can be
refined from each other actually
described the same thing that's in order
to bring in an element of abstraction
into our reasoning and reflects if I
think is is a matter of convenience
unless anybody can think of a good
reason why the thing has to be reflexive
one could have worked with an
irreflexive order it doesn't matter very
much
I find the reflexive one more convenient
so now let's start talking about
programs programming languages and
descriptions and specifications
one of the fundamental operators of a
programming language is sequential
composition denoted by semicolon and
that's what I intend to mean by
semicolon when I write it between two
program descriptions informally and when
I construct a model of the algebra I'm
going to ensure the state that each
execution are described by P semicolon Q
consists of two parts can be split into
two parts the first part of which
consists of all events from X all events
from an execution of P and the second
part consists of an execution
q and those events are distinct from
each other and subject to an ordering
constraint that reflects the fact that P
in some sense comes before Q but I'm not
going to tell you exactly what that
ordering constraint is I'm going to
suggest some possible meanings for it
for example the strong meaning could say
all events X from P must precede all
events from Q in other words P must
finish before Q starts and a lot of
people other people think that that is
what semicolon means in a programming
language but people who actually write
compilers for computers such as this
know that that isn't what it means it
actually means something a little weaker
than that
it says no event from Q the second
operand can precede any event from P but
they could occur at the same time the
events at the beginning of Q could occur
at the same time as events from the end
of P provided of course that they don't
affect the same variables in the memory
there are two there's another
distinction that you can draw whether
the sequential composition is
interrupted all or not whether it's
possible for other threads to interfere
between the execution of P and the
execution of Q or whether the interrupts
are as it were inhibited during the
transition between P and Q all we want
to say is that our algebraic laws are
going to apply equally to each of those
four cases so I don't have to tell you
which but that's all I'm interested is
the abstraction that the algebraic law
makes from the details of the way in
which sequential composition is
implemented
ah come to something more familiar I'm
actually going to define I mean in 1969
I didn't know any better and I
postulated this as a primitive of the
reasoning about programs and a lot of
people have followed that example but
now I'm going to define it algebraically
is just the statement that he composed
sequentially with Q refines R and one
could read that as saying that starting
in the final state of an execution of P
Q will end in a final state of some
execution of our you see P n R maybe
will be mostly assertions in fact
post-conditions because we're talking
about the end of execution but there's
no reason in the algebra why they should
be post-conditions
any specification any program will do so
we can describe the initial state of Q
by just writing a program P that will
bring a machine into that initial State
there's complete flexibility expressive
power of the whole programming language
can be used to actually specify
preconditions post conditions and other
aspects of specifications here's a
little example we have the usual example
X becomes X plus 1 and in the brackets
on the Left we have an execution that
ends with X plus 1 equal or less than n
and the R on the right says that X is
equal less than n
ah some more laws semicolon is monotonic
with respect to refinement does every
book the definition of monotonicity is
given in the next two lines one saying
that the semicolon is monotonic in its
first argument and the other one in
saying that it is monotonic in its
second argument except I should have
should have scrubbed out these was there
yes yes
algebra is nice and simple and the only
errors you have are the obvious ones
well this is a property that is shared
with if so if P and Q were numbers and
semicolon was plus then monotonicity
holds for normal arithmetic addition so
it's a familiar property the rule of
consequence was one of the very first
rules that I put forward for the
calculus of hoar triples and I've quoted
that it says that if you weaken the
precondition or strengthen the sorry if
you strengthen the precondition or
weaken the post condition the triple is
still true and I thought that was very
young that actually follows from the
first law now if anybody like to count
the number of symbols in that first law
and a number of symbols here the free
free variables number of free variables
has gone up and the number of symbols
has gone up and if you look back at the
definition of the whole triple you'll
see that there are actually more symbols
in the thing that that was defined
rather than the mathematical meaning
which I'm giving it here it's very
unusual in mathematics to see a to
define something which actually takes
more symbols than the expression that
you're defining is in terms of we
normally think of definitions as being
abbreviations don't we but in this case
I seem to have managed to not realize
that and I get my comeuppance that every
theorem that I write is nearly twice as
long as the algebraic law on which
is based no that seems to me to have
been something of a mistake
certainly a result of ignorance not was
not what I intended so let's go on and
postulate another law that the semicolon
is associative doesn't matter in which
order you take the operands there is a
similar law which expresses how you
prove the correctness of a semicolon
using four triples and that this law
follows from half of that law if you
replace that equality by a refinement
you find that the law will improve this
will approve we'll prove this theorem
and vice versa you can derive the
theorem from the law so the whole triple
rule for a sequential composition is not
only nearly twice as long as the law
from which it is derived but it's only
half as powerful hmm absol I get
yes that's a right is a misprint ah it's
a crime I tried to rub it out with my
finger with the program that does
nothing skip often called and the
important algebraic property of it is
that it is a unit of semicolon and from
this law I can prove that the standard
triple definition of the skip operation
it does nothing so anything that was
true before remains true afterwards in
this case the law is only one quarter as
powerful as the theorem you can prove
one in equation in one direction only
from the from the theorem well that was
easy
can we do the same thing for concurrent
composition where we have two threads
operating in simultaneously perhaps even
on the same computer perhaps even
sharing the same store perhaps
communicating with each other or
whatever and here the intended meaning
is that all events of an execution of
each of the threaded threads is included
in the execution when you run them
concurrently everything that happens is
either attributed to the execution of a
command inside P or to an execution of a
command inside Q there's nothing more
nothing less but this time there's no
constraint they can occur the events of
P and the events of Q can occur they can
occur one after the other all they're
kind of personal taneous ly or they can
occur concurrently so that they run
during the same in
all of time just as in the case of
sequential composition does more than
one possible meaning one could give to
this operator for example does it mean
concurrency on separate computers which
don't share store or which dutour do
share store does it mean that the origin
is implemented by interleaving so that
the every event occurs either before or
after an event of the other thread I'm
not going to say which of those it is
because the laws will apply to both of
them both of them are associative
commutative and monotonic
now the way to which has been suggested
for reasoning about concurrency is
widely widely widely known and a new
technique for reasoning about
concurrency is given by separation logic
and the most important property of
separation logic is one that I've
written here that if you've proved a
given triple then you can run something
else in concurrently with the
precondition and the post condition
remember these are precondition post
condition are themselves descriptions of
a program execution so we can describe s
running concurrently with R or with P
and this implication is the basis for
the simplicity of reasoning about
correctness in separation logic if you
translate you can you can actually
translate this triple formulation back
into the original algebra you'll get a
statement which is I've called left
locality which is a sort of distribution
law showing how concurrency distributes
into a sequential composition it relates
the two operators it's a property of the
relationship between sequential and
concurrent composition which is very
similar to the distribution laws which
relate addition and multiplication in
conventional numerical algebra so but
you actually distribute this s to only
one of the operands rather than the
other it's equally true you could have
distributed to the second operand rather
than the first
but that requires an additional axiom
right locality now the second law which
separation logic allows is a sort of
compositionality or modularity law which
tells you that if you want to prove a
the correctness of a sequential
composition then you should prove the
correctness of the two operands of the
sequential composition and that enables
you to conclude that the composition
itself is correct
and in this case again the law implies
the theorem but in this case the theorem
also implies the law if you want your
semicolon to be modular you start if you
want your reasoning about concurrency to
be modular then you have to believe that
law there's not it's not not optional
and that's quite interesting but is it
true is that lourd true is that the
right question well we want it to be
true don't we because we want to reason
modular lis and if I were a pure algebra
it merely wanting the law to be true
would be enough but hmm not for an
applied scientists we really do need to
find at least something of which that
law is true well this is an an active
topic of research which I won't get
shortly give you an example meanwhile
let me just write out the exchange law
in a slightly different form in a
2-dimensional form in which the P and
the P dashed are distributed in this way
now if you
read the read this matrix horizontally
it reads P concurrent with Q all
composed sequentially with P - two
concurrent with Q dashed and if we go to
the next slide we're reading reading it
by rows rather than by columns that P
composed with P dashed yeah
parallel this one with Q composed with Q
dashed so this this law is really a sort
of asserting the two dimensionality of
what
concurrency gives us the it's as though
we are manipulating events controlling
events not just occurring in the single
dimensional of time as we do in in
sequential programming but also in the
dimension of space and so things that
are separated by the parallel occur as
it were in a different place from those
which are separated by from that from
its two operands and the exchange law
says you can transpose that matrix that
the two axes are to certain extent
orthogonal to each other this is a
rather hand waving description I'm
afraid but it is difficult to see
understand the real inwardness of that
exchange law so let me get on to the
final question is is it true or rather
as we put it in the research of what is
there anything of which it is true well
what is it true of
and I'm going to end my talk with a
claim that it is true of a concurrency
or rather of interleaving of regular
languages so my P Q and R are
descriptions of the execution of a
finite state machine for limited limited
machine for executing programs P refines
Q means that the language is that the
behavior of the machine is defined in
terms of strings and the refinement
means that every string which could
possibly be an execution of P is also an
execution of Q or R in other words the
there are languages are included the
semicolon is the standard semicolon of
regular expressions it's the lifted
concatenation of strings and parallel Q
is the interleaving of strings a
perfectly good operator on on regular
languages because it preserves finite
you'd the empty string is the unit of
semicolon and the individual characters
of the alphabet of the machine are are
the generators of the of the algebra the
but I won't be dealing with those so now
I've got to show that the left locality
law is true because I needed that to to
prove the load proves the frame lenore
of separation logic so look at the left
hand side you can see that s interleaves
just with p and all of q comes
afterwards i've drawn a picture here
here's all of q coming afterwards
and here is s interleaving with with P
in this case P came first and then then
tooth to possibly different symbols from
s on the right hand side there has been
a little bit more into leaving because
the s and the Q have changed places so
there's more interleavings on the right
hand side than there are on the left
hand side and that's why it works
another way of stating the truth sort of
more construct exposing we were told
please find us and interleaving this one
here between s and P semicolon Q one of
the ways of finding such an interleaving
is to the side first of all have all of
Q at the end and then to interleave s
with P so refinement expresses the fact
that one of the ways of implementing
this specification is to take this as
its design
and here's the exchange law it's a
little bit more complicated but again I
can give you the informal explanation
that the if you want to interleave two
long strings long sequential strings
then one of the things you can do is you
can split the first bit of string and
split the second ring and then
interleave the first elements of the two
of operands and follow that by
interleaving the second element so it is
an interleaving in which the two
semicolons occurring on the right hand
side have been synchronized to
synchronize those two semicolons it
follows that the left of that semicolon
is an interleaving of the two left
operands of the semicolon on the
right-hand side and similarly on the
right-hand side now it was quite a shock
to me to discover that regular
interleaving actually satisfies the same
law same laws as separation logic
because the whole purpose of separation
logic is to avoid interleaving
interleaving interleavings are race
conditions and those are the things we
want to avoid and yet to reason about
interleavings we use exactly the same
reasoning principles same algebraic laws
as we do for for truly separate threads
so I've gone through all the details but
the conclusion is that regular
expressions satisfy all our laws for
refinement sequential composition skip
and interleaving and actually for many
of the other operators that I won't have
time to introduce later
well I hope if you don't believe any of
the details of what I've been talking
about you will go away with the
impression that I am extremely pretty
impressed by the power of algebra the
algebraic laws turned out to be much
more simple than the what I was
originally familiar with or triple
they're reusable I can use the same laws
and the same theories based on them for
many different operators and for many
different languages and many different
operators within the same language they
are unifying in the sense that I've just
described and indeed in another sense
because all triples aren't the only way
of describing the semantics of a
programming language there are
operational semantics there are there
are two versions of or triples one of
them for total correctness and the other
one for partial correctness and they're
different and they have different
algebraic definitions and there are at
least two different kinds of operational
semantics which are due to Plotkin and
and used by Milner which actually
describe how to execute a program and
those those presentations of the
semantics are of course more useful for
actually implementing the language than
the deductive presentation which is
given in hoar logic and in order for a
practical level programming language
really well it must have an operational
semantics it must be operational you
must be able to execute the program so
there isn't any point in it and it's
nice also to be able to prove that the
programs are correct even if you never
actually do it so what we need is a
combination of deductive proof methods
for establishing the properties of
programs and inductive methods of
actually executing the programs which we
hope
we now believe to be correct they can
all all these forms of semantics can be
derived from the algebra that I shown
you and the algebra of other operators
which I haven't done haven't had time to
show you and vice-versa if you take the
conjunction of all the forms of
semantics and prove the thing backwards
you can prove all the laws of the
algebra from four different versions of
programming language semantics but the
algebra is much simpler and much shorter
than four different complete semantic
presentations of semantics of a language
so algebra is abstract I think we've
seen that and I hope I've managed to
convey some part of the my admiration
for the elegance of some of the
algebraic formulations thank you very
much
5950 659 one-hour exactly
first have you done so faster to get
just watch
Thanks
wonderful don't like induction very much
induction depends on the exclude I think
perhaps I could make two observations
from what you said the first one is but
I'm very glad that you raised this point
because it shows that if you're
interested in taking things further
Patrick will be able to enlighten you
you are you've described you've
described the content of my second
lecture the second thing is that one of
the nice things about algebra is its
incrementality that I can tell you a lot
a great deal or not everything but a
great deal about semicolon and
interleaving and refinement and I don't
have to mention whether it's a lattice
ordering or not and simply by adding a
new axiom or a new operator to my
algebra together with an Associated
axiom or definition I can extend my
language without changing anything that
has gone before and this is really I
think an essential criterion for
progress in science that it builds on
what has gone before rather than
overthrowing it why sometimes it needs
overthrowing but but a building is the
normal thing to do for a scientist and
the ability to to build on not just the
foundations but the theorems the first
and second floors can be standard and
then you can add new things without
invalidating anything that's gone before
if you use too much induction
particularly induction on the syntax you
can't do this because an induction
depends on limiting the range of
operators or number
or objects that you're dealing with so
that you can deal with them by cases so
that I think there's a very very
important point about algebra here and I
can say some very rude things about the
other forms of semantics you I expect
you seen at least 4,000 different
languages defined using operation or
deductive semantics every one of them as
far as I know maybe wrong quotes every
law that it uses every every rule that
it proposes and reproves
every theorem that it needs and that is
why maybe our subject is not progressing
as fast as it should
algebra is marvelous
on when you see them having - what
lessons
to get the same simplification
well I know that what I found in in in
recent years when I was an academic I
used to say well you shouldn't be using
programming languages that that go
beyond what I know how to prove and
since joining Microsoft I've realized
that this is an untenable position but
as a result I've learnt an enormous
amount all this stuff about concurrency
arises out of the fact that it's needed
and so by studying what actually is and
I mean what is in the languages that
people actually use I've managed I think
to extend the range of the research into
the principles of programming so I I
think there's a lot in current practice
and current languages from which a quite
theoretical an interesting theoretical
areas of our research can be can be
derived if I believed that there would
be a lot of new programming languages
invented in this world and then used by
others people other than their inventors
then I would suggest that one uses the
algebra is a tool for discussing the
programming language design and since I
don't believe that many new new
programming languages will be designed I
will apply the same principles to
programs to api's to protocols to any
other human interface which the
programmer wishes to offer or sell to
his colleagues try to formulate try to
discuss the way you do the way you
discuss your design of an API in terms
of its algebraic properties it just
gives you a medium for considering
alternatives
and when you've chosen the alternatives
you might be very kind to explain to
your potential users what they are
certainly if you're going to build tools
that are going to analyze the programs
which used your your constructions then
you're going to need some theory on
which to base those tools and the tools
could be quite important to get it
getting your designs accepted and used
reliably by people who if they don't
understand what your interface does at
least could in principle understand it
by reading the reading the laws
stop gently and you have a lot of
chapters and if I assume this actually
then I have been services amplifiers of
this other
here you have branching
is known in between I think
three that lets you speed up into yours
no I would welcome it when you do have
to make a distinction you have to make a
distinction you say I'm afraid this
doesn't mix details don't mix with some
other branch of the of the subject
unification is not is not cramming
everything into the same basket it is
welcoming the branching structure of the
subject and basing the draw the
structure on as it were the inner logic
of the mathematics involved and
explaining it and making it completely
clear what the implications of making a
decision to go down one branch or the
other are going to be so the pattern of
a mathematical text book that you've
very eloquently described and very
faithfully described is one that I would
love to see reproduced when talking
about the principles of programming
can you model your call well ideally it
sort of all of mathematics involves
procedure calls you just define
something and then you then you use it
so this one would prefer to avoid having
to model the implementations of power of
parameter passing mechanisms if that's
what you want
can semicolon do that no there is
clearly a declarations not only of
procedures but of variables that need to
be included in the language and I think
specifications interfaces too
one of the nice things I discovered
recently was a way of implementing the
requires and and insurers of bougie as
an operator of the language that
delivers I an explicit error message as
it were if the program doesn't meet its
specification but which enables the user
of the the person who calls the
procedure to assume that it satisfies
the specification and allows the
implementer to use the body of the
procedure to actually implement it so
it's a little operator with algebraic
properties based on on lease up of
greatest lower bounds in this case
the operator that choice do you have
negation
and
let me discuss about the fundamental
distinction perhaps linear programming
specifications mystery our logical
specification yes you have negation in
logic but programs
yes I think the the that's that's a very
good very good point in specification is
very often very really essential to have
very simple concepts like and or or not
but in programs there is a very good
reason for not allowing not it's in
computable there's a very good reason
for not having non determinism because
it makes testing impossible so we get
sequential languages which are
deterministic and certainly we don't
have we don't have not and in fact there
are other the so it turns out that the
programs are really a subset of
specifications it's very interesting to
to determine the algebraic properties of
that subset is that because it's a
subset it has more interesting algebraic
properties than general specifications
so in some ways it it's a good thing
that programs are a special case but it
certainly means that it well it actually
means that the process of program
designed from specification actually has
some significance it means you've got a
specification which is as clear as you
can make it using concepts like and or
and not and then you've got to somehow
massage that specification into form
that doesn't use and or or not but only
operators like semicolon and concurrency
and so on and that that's what
programming is all about in principle
program lenses based on construction
projects and construct a finite series
in which the languages associations and
programs are indeed included and things
like not exists both with level of
specifications and
I wasn't aware that not existed level of
programs but not being just a function
that takes a position
watch
yes I mean it essentially collapses the
program into false that's right yes yes
well no I have a great admiration for
clearly they tend to restrict the
programming language in ways that at
least for Microsoft is unrealistic
because it's a pure functional
programming language and nearly every
program written by Microsoft is
non-deterministic it's not not even a
function quite apart from the fact that
the very essence of what Microsoft deals
with and indeed a lot of other software
is involves time and space trading off
between time and space is what
programmers these days have to do and
functional programs are marvelous
because you don't have to do it as a
result we can't use functional programs
for everything
we are always pure honest about that
statement setting trends
I think that's another it's a very funny
thing about functional programming
people get quite quite enthusiastic
about it but when you come down to it
they all put procedural features into
their implementations just the way the
Fortran did I mean Fortran loves
functions
it included functions way back in 1960
56 % thank you
thank you you remember that was before
my time
it's just that they they describe these
things in in in different ways
enthusiastic Fortran programmer can say
yep yes we've got functions and you
should use them whenever you can and the
functional programmer puts the
procedural facilities into its language
and says yes it's got procedural
facilities but you should avoid them
whenever you can and I agree with both
of those